let's get to audience questions I love
this first one because it's something
I've thought about for a very very long
time really since I first became engaged
in politics when I was in high school
the question is hey David how could
anyone still be undecided about whether
or not they're going to vote for Donald
Trump I also want to know how this is
possible and it seems to me that there's
a few different things going on I mean I
actually want to know how is it possible
to really be a swing vote or do they not
know or pay attention to what the
parties and candidates represent are
they voting based on personalities or
physical appearance or something else it
has never really made sense to me and I
think that there's a couple of different
things going on first of all a lot of
these swing voters are uninformed and
I'm not saying this as a pejorative
we've seen we've analyzed in fact a lot
of interviews with voters who one was
with a group of women who said I voted
Obama in 2012 and then I voted Trump in
2016 they were clueless I mean they
didn't know anything about what was
going on so I think part of it is that
they are unaware of the facts and
probably making decisions on the basis
of rhetoric that they are not then
researching the truth of they are
falling for the talking points of one
versus the other I don't think it's
particularly good for our society I mean
listen I'd rather between Obama and
Trump I'm voting for Obama as a society
I don't know that we're better off for
people falling for either candidates or
either parties talking points in terms
of what it means about critical thinking
and the ability to analyze assertions
for yourself but there there is that
element first and foremost people who
just don't really know what's going on
um there's another thing though that I
think needs to be mentioned when we talk
about
the undecideds and the swing voters and
the independence which is there is a
sort of psychological pleasure that some
people get by being the enlightened
centrist and you see that there are
actually some media people who have
YouTube channels or whatever based on
the idea that they are independent and
they are centrists and
they will sometimes vote for Republicans
and sometimes vote for Democrats is it
possible that someone's ideology might
sometimes point to voting for a
Republican and other times point to
voting for a Democrat absolutely its
more common in very local races it's
much less common for example at the
Senate level I'm sure we can find
examples where you have you know a very
a Democrat that's conservative on issues
you disagree with them on and a
Republican who is more liberal for
example on issues where you agree so you
might vote for the Republican over these
are very rare cases so I've met a lot of
people who get some kind of satisfaction
from sort of feeling as though they are
above the peons who are on the left or
on the right Democrats or Republicans
but I actually think it's often they who
are the ignorant ones because they seem
to they seem to interpret centrism as
being more discerning and more
fact-based when it comes to deciding who
to vote for when in reality they're
missing that the differences between
Republicans and Democrats left and right
the differences are so obvious that to
be the enlightened centrist is the
furthest thing from enlighten that you
could possibly be so I think that that's
also a part of it is the combination of
some people who are uninformed some
people who like the idea of just being
contrarian and saying I'm a different
thing I'm not like you guys and I'm not
like you guys I'm just the I'm the
centrist I sometimes book this way
sometimes the other way everyone that
I've personally talked to and this is
merely anecdotal when you ask them about
their politics their politics actually
make it very clear you should always be
voting for a Democrat or you should
always have been voting for a Republican
you just don't seem to realize it for
yourself it's it's sort of a sad
commentary about education in the United
States you then also have voters who are
just not very politically engaged and
and they like to say I vote for whoever
is best in a particular election and
very often that has nothing to do with
policy at all it actually is personality
and the way that the person campaigns
and sort of a feeling that someone gets
judge that as you will in terms of
whether that's a good thing or not a
good thing but yeah I also don't really
understand I mean listen if today if
someone is unsure whether they are
voting for a Democrat or Trump I want to
hear from you even the furthest right
Democrat which I guess would be who's
furthest right I mean is it like Biden
of the people that are still in it Biden
followed by Budaj edges I guess of the
people that are that are still in the
running are the furthest right of course
I'm voting for them on over Donald Trump
and I would be very interested to hear
during live calls from someone who might
vote for Trump or vite might vote for a
Democrat I want to hear on what issue is
it that is keeping you from deciding